this is my favorite video it was going
around the internet yesterday a group of
young idiots
the protesters very peaceful were
throwing objects at a car as it was
driving by because most people just keep
driving right not this guy this guy he
was not going to take a ding on his car
lying down so he's driving the hit his
car he stops then he starts to back up
and then you hear the peaceful
protestors say my my three favorite
words of this of this whole incident
call the police
do you see me stops he's backing up oh
[Music]
I'll call the police
multiple people please no you know that
those brutal people who are slaughtering
innocent men and women all over this
country yeah call him call them now cuz
this guy is gonna be upset that I loose
it all and the guy runs out of his car
with something I don't even know what
this guy he's holding he chases the one
idiot away the guy goes running and then
he turns on the rest of the crowd by the
way this this is one man one older man
facing down like I don't know probably
eight or nine people and they all
scatter and run the minute that anybody
pushes back whatsoever they're gonna
hurl objects they're gonna break windows
they're gonna steal stuff they're gonna
burn down cities until they get any
pushback whatsoever but we haven't
gotten any pushback yet other than this
wild looking guy and so the chaos rages
on and the response from our elected
leaders is to defund the cops and our
response from our media establishment is
to encourage the protests if these
people in that video had one ounce of
self awareness they would hang it all up
the moment that they said call the
police and they would say they throw the
object the guy would turn around they'd
say oh no call the police oh oh right
okay now I understand nevermind I'm
gonna go home everybody go home civil
order is a good thing but they're so
full of anger they're so full of fury
that they can't even realize that
[Music]
you
[Music]